E
ARE MOVING TO NEW JERSEY.
LET'S TURN TO ROB O'DONNELL.
HE IS A RETIRED NYPD DETECTIVE
WHO JOINS ME NOW.
SO THIS IS A NICE NEIGHBORHOOD.
THE NYPD WAS ON THIS WOMAN.
SHE IS A SERIAL PILFERER AND
THEY TRACKED HER TO, AS I SAID,
MY FRIEND'S BOBBY TOWN HOUSE,
WHICH HE HAS NEVER INVITED ME.
TO SAY THAT'S FINE.
THEY CAUGHT HER IN THE ACT.
I MEAN, IF THIS CAN HAPPEN TO
HIM, THIS CAN HAPPEN TO ANYBODY.
WHAT ARE WE GOING TO DO ABOUT
THIS?
>> WELL, BURGLARIES CITYWIDE
ALMOST UP 24%.
HERE IS A CAREER CRIMINAL.
IT 26.
MOSTLY BURGLARIES.
SKIPPED OUT ON COURT ORDERED
DRUG PROGRAM.
HERE SHE IS BREAKING INTO
SOMEONE'S HOUSE WITH THEIR
10-YEAR-OLD CHILD SLEEPING
UPSTAIRS.
IF THIS WAS NOT JUST A PROPERTY
CRIME INDIVIDUALS.
THIS WAS A VIOLENT CRIMINAL
LOOKING TO HURT SOMEONE OKAY
HAVE HAD ANOTHER TRAGEDY ON YOUR
HANDS.
VIOLENT CRIME IS UP 33%
CITYWIDE.
>> SO, IF THE JUDGE SEES THIS
WOMAN GETTING GET IN FRONT OF
HIS BENCH, AND HE DOESN'T GIVE
ANY BAIL, HE JUST LETS HER OUT
AND SAYS YOU GO TO DRUG REHAB,
HE IS LOOKING AT A RAP SHEET A
MILE LONG.
DRUG REHAB?
WHAT IS HE THINKING?
>> UNFORTUNATELY, OUR GREAT
LEGISLATORS IN ALBANY HAVE TIED
THE HANDS OF OUR JUDGES.
AS YOU CAN HE SO THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT IS ACTIVELY OUT
THERE.
WHAT IS IRONIC ABOUT IT THEY
CALL IT THE PUBLIC SAFETY TEAM.
THESE INDIVIDUAL WERE THE OLD
STREET CRIME, OLD ANTICRIME
LABELED AS THE BAD POLICE
OFFICERS IN NEW YORK CITY.
THIS IS WHAT THEY DO.
THEY ARE LETTING THE POLICE BE
THE POLICE.
THEY HAVE RELABELED THEM.
THEY ARE TRACKING THESE
CRIMINALS.
THE 19TH PRECINCT TELLS ME ONE
OF THE TOP FIVE BURGLARY
SUSPECTS THIS YEAR.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE OUT THERE
PURSUING AND TAKING OFF THE
STREET.
THEY HAVE TAKEN HER OFF THE
STREET 26 TIMES.
>> Jesse: WHAT'S THE MENTALITY
OF NYPD IF THEY KEEP ARRESTING
THE SAME PEOPLE AND REARREST
THEM DAY AFTER DAY?
>> IT'S FRUSTRATING AND THAT'S
WHY YOU ARE SEEING A MASS EXODUS
OF THE NYPD.
SEEING THE LACK OF RECRUITMENT
TO COME BACK TO THE NYPD.
YOU HAVE A MAYOR WHO TOUTED
HIMSELF AS A FORMER POLICE
OFFICER WHO NEVER DID -- I
WORKED WITH ERIC ADAMS IN THE
TRANSIT POLICE IN THE 1990s.
HE DOES NOT HAVE THE SKILL SET
TO LEAD A POLICE DEPARTMENT LIKE
HE PORTRAYED DURING HIS
CAMPAIGN.
>> Jesse: WHAT WAS ADAMS LIKE
WHEN YOU WORKED WITH HIM BACK IN
THE DAY?
>> WELL, HE WAS REALLY GOOD AT
SITTING AT HIS DESK.
I DON'T BELIEVE HE HAS MORE THAN
A HANDFUL OF ARRESTS FOR HIS
20-YEAR CAREER WHERE ARE, YOU
KNOW, YOUR ACTIVE OFFICERS HAVE
FOUR AND 500 ARRESTS.
I THINK THAT SPEAKS FOR ITSELF.
>> Jesse: THAT'S INTERESTING.